في ليبيا وصل المبعوث الخاصه امم المتحده
عبد الله باتيلي الى مدينه سرت لرعايه
جوله جديده من اجتماعات اللجنه العسكريه
المشتركه خمسه زائد خمسه ويعد سنه وانشطه
هذه اللجنه من اولويات البتيري منذ تعيينه
شهر سبتمبر الماضي حيث ستتركز المباحثات
بجان توحيد المؤسسه العسكريه الليبيه
وانهاء حاله انقسام معنا من اسطنبول
وتنميه هناك سيد السنوسي كيف نفهم عوده
هذه اللجنه للعقاد بعد كل هذا التعثر
عودته هو التركيز الدولي الاطراف الدوليه
بالذات العواصم الغربيه بقياده واشنطن
والبعثه البعثه الاميه كاداه لاداره
النزاع الدائره في البلاد هذه الاطراف
تركز على المسار الامني وتعتبر بان احتواء
النزاع
العسكري مهم جدا لدفع العجله للامام
وتسهيل عمليه التوافق السياسي فاذا في
تركيز من قبل اطراف الدوليه ومن قبل
البعثه الاميه على تنشيط المسار الامني
وانجحه
انا لسابع ذلك يعني كما قلت بان الرؤيه
رؤيه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عواصم
اوروبيه مهمه البعثه الاميه ترى بان
التطور على المستوى العسكري والوصول الى
الاهداف التي تم التوافق عليها وهي اخراج
المرتزقه الاجانب بتحديد الروس وهذه الملف
الروس مقلق للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وتوحيد المؤسسه العسكريه اعتقد بانها من
ضمن اجنده باريس في برينس في في لقاء مع
خليفه حفتر باعتبار انه ملف حيوي للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لانه يتعلق بوجود
الروسي ودور
ورقه مهمه لموسكو وهي قواتنا همم في همم
عرض قناه المسار الامني وعرقله بالتالي
المسار السياسي وهل بات هناك قاعده تنطلق
منها اللجنه الان لتحقيق هاتين نقطتين
تحديدا اخراج القوات الاجنبيه وايضا تكوين
القوه المشتركه بالنظر لمعطيات ليبيا
الحليب
انا اعتقد ان المشكله يعني ليست باليسيره
وهي عصيه على الحل لاسباب عده منها ان طرف
الصراع في الشرق والغرب لها نظره مختلفه
للقضايا المطروحه على الطاوله على سبيل
المثال توحيد المؤسسه العسكريه
الرجمه بقياده حفتر ينظر الى القوات في
الغرب لابني انها ميليشيات بل وحتى
مجموعات متورطه في ارهاب وانها يجب
تفكيكها ولا يمكن اعتبارا ضمن البناء
العسكري الجديد في الغرب ينظرون الى حفتر
انه استخدموا مسمى الجيش واعطائه صفه
لمجموعات تتورط في في في جرائم حرب وفي
تجاوزات وخروقات وانتهاكات الحقوق الانسان
فاذا شكل الجيش هيكليه الجيش القادمه يعني
خلاف حاد حول من سيقود الجيش الجبهه
الغربيه ترفض ان يكون لحفتر اي يدور في
الهيكليه الجديده للقوات المسلحه في
الشاطئ يعتبرون ان الخلاص الوحيد واستقرار
المؤسسه العسكريه يكون قياده حفتر فاذا
قضايا جدليه مهمه النقطه الثانيه وهي وجود
القوات الاجنبيه اخراج القوات الاجنبيه
متعلق بتنازع
اقليمي دولي
روسيا تعتبر بان الفاكنر ورقه مهمه جدا في
مواجهه الغرب والصراحه على دوائر واسعه
منها الحرف اوكرانيا
تركيا انه وجودها مهم جدا لتحقيق مصالح
استراتيجيه بالنسبه
اخراج المرتزقه مرتبط بازاعات وتقاطعات
اقلاميه ليس من اليسير حلها هذا يعيدنا
الى الجنسيه التي تحدث فيها عن الاراده
الغربيه والاراده الدوليه لحاله الازمه
نجاح اعمال هذه اللجنه المشتركه ولكن ماذا
عن الاراده الليبيه اذا وفق هذه معطيات
التي جاءت على ذكرها
للاسف لان الخلاف الخلاف في جذري كما قلت
بين الطرفين يعني الجبهه الغربيه ما تزال
تعتبر بيننا اعاده هيكله المؤسسه العسكريه
وتكون جيش جديد
يجب ان لا يخضع للشخصنا بمعنى انه الطرف
الغربي اعضاء خمسه زائد خمسه من الجبهه
الشرقيه المكلفه من قبل حفتر يعتبرون
النقاش حول عزل حفتر من منصب العسكري هذا
امر مرفوض كمان ولا يمكن حتى يخضاء على
النقاش الطرف الثاني يعتبر بان ازمه ليبيا
متمثله في استمرار وجود حفتر على راس او
هرم السلطه العسكريه
يبقى اذا السؤال هل ستستطيع اراده الغربيه
ان تهزم كل هذه التحديات وتقرب وجهه النظر
المستقبلي لهذا المشهد في ليبيا اشكرك
السيد مدير المركز الليبي للبحوث والتنميه